we have come a long way from storing
stuff on our computers to using the
cloud which is like a giant virtual
storage the amount of data we have is
expected to explode to
175 zettabytes by 2025 that's a lot of
information to handle and that's where
cloud computing comes to the rescue a
gamechanging technology in today's
digital world has transformed how we do
things is the driving force behind
sharing emails videos and running
businesses with ease so getting
certified in Cloud technology is like
getting the key to this digital Treasure
Chest companies are moving their stuff
to the cloud because it's safe flexible
and cost effective as organizations
increasingly migrate to the cloud the
demand for skilled professionals who can
design manage and secure Cloud
environments is skyrocketing so whether
you are a seasoned IT professional or
just starting your Tech Journey a cloud
certification not only signifies your
commitment to staying ahead but also
opens the door to exciting opportunity
ities in this Dynamic field so here we
are with the top five Cloud
certifications you should watch out for
in 2024 hey everyone and you are already
watching simply Lo before we begin with
the top five Cloud certifications make
sure that you have subscribed to our
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to never miss any updates from Simply so
without any further delay let's get
started let me share some fascinating
statistics with you that illustrate the
impact and potential of this
gamechanging technology before we delve
into the fascinating world of cloud
computing certifications so according to
glass door the average salary of a cloud
engineer is $1 142,00 in the United
States and in India is 7.5 lakh rupees
perom with additional cash benefit so
let's move on to the top five cloud
computing certifications for
2024 at number one we have the cloud
architect Masters program this program
will help you build your AWS Microsoft
Azure and Google Cloud platform
expertise from from the ground up you
will learn to master the architectural
principles and services of the top Cloud
platforms design and deploy highly
scalable fall tolerant applications and
develop skills to transform yourself
into an AWS and Azure Cloud expert this
program will give you an in-depth
understanding of cloud services such as
AWS cloud formation Azure resource
manager ec2 S3 Route 53 wepc Azure app
services gcp and more you'll acquire the
Knowledge and Skills for passing Cloud
architect certifications such as AWS
architect and Azure architect Cloud
architecture certification program
consists of a structured learning path
designed by leading industry experts
you'll have access to 60 plus live
instructor-led online classrooms 100
plus hours of self-paced video content
simulation exams a community moderated
by experts and other resources that
ensure you follow the optimal path to
your desired role of cloud architect the
course includes 16 plus real world
industry projects that let you work your
way through the technical challenges
associated with cloud computing
candidates with one plus year of
experience are preferred to enroll in
this program so do check out the link
mentioned in the description box below
for more details at number two we have
the AWS Cloud architect Masters
program this AWS Cloud architect
certification course will make you an
expert in Amazon web services in this
program you'll become familiar with the
architectural principles at and services
of AWS learn how to design and deploy
highly scalable and fall tolerant
applications on Amazon web services
Implement AWS security and testing and
become an expert in AWS components such
as S3 and cloud formation this AWS Cloud
architect certification training will
enable you to master the course skills
required for Designing and deploying
dynamically scalable highly available
fall tolerant and reliable applications
on one of the top Cloud providers the
Amazon web services so candidates with
one plusus years of experience are
preferred to enroll in this program for
more details check out the link
mentioned in the description box below
moving on to number three at number
three we have the Azure Cloud architect
Masters program Azure Cloud architect
Masters program will help you master the
Azure infrastructure by understanding
Azure Cloud architect Technology
Solutions implementing workloads and
Security in Azo creating and deploying
apps in Azo and securing data in
Microsoft azo
a Microsoft Azure certification
validates your Cloud skills and
demonstrate your expertise for a given
role it can help you improve your
earning potential and stay ahead of your
peers it is predicted that around 80% of
all Enterprise workloads will move to
the cloud by 2025 this means that there
will be high demand for professionals
who can develop Cloud applications and
manage cloud infrastructures and a
Microsoft Azure training certification
will help you gain these skills also
candidate with OnePlus years of
experience are preferred to enroll in
this program so for more details check
out the link mentioned in the
description box below moving on to
number four at number four we have
professional certificate program in
cloud computing and devops with a
professional certificate programm in
cloud computing and devops with E and
ICT Academy IIT guahati become an Azure
AWS devops and Cloud infrastructure
design expert gain hands-on experience
through our real well projects for an
exciting career in it our programs offer
comprehensive training on designing and
implementing Solutions using AWS and
Azure you'll also gain Proficiency in
Cloud architecture infrastructure design
Administration and automation so prepare
for certifications acquire Real World
skills and boost your cloud and devops
career this program covers multiple
skills like application migration Cloud
workloads autoscaling Web Services and
apis database management multicloud
deployment Cloud migration and
deployment disaster recovery and many
more candidates with OnePlus year of
work experience are preferred to enroll
in this program and for more details
check out the link mentioned in the
description box below at number five we
have cloud computing boot camp by ctech
ctme becoming an expert in AWS and Azure
is made easy with the celtech cloud
computing boot camp this in-depth online
course equips you with the essential
skills and Architectural principles
needed to excel in cloud computing
Master the yard of cloud technology and
become a sought after Cloud expert this
program includes 40 plus handson
projects and integrated Labs Capstone
projects in four different domains
simply learn career service helps you
get noticed by the top hiring companies
and keltech ctme boot camp certificate
validates your expertise so join the
simply learn cloud computing boot camp
and unlock a world of opportunities in
this rapidly expanding field candidates
with one plus years of work experience
are preferred to enroll in this program
so visit our website today to enroll and
take the first step toward becoming a
certified cloud computing professional
link to this program is mentioned in the
description box below with that we have
come to the end of this video on top
five cloud computing certifications in
2024 now let's take a minute to hear it
out from our Learners who have
experienced massive success in their
careers with simply learn hey I am Salah
qura and I am currently living I wanted
to experience what is like to leave I
also realized that to get a new job I
needed to have a professional
certification in cloud computing so last
year I started the postgraduate program
in cloud computing in association with C
with this course I had the choice to
study while I continue and that is how I
got this new job offer with 60% salary
high in Finland I will be leading the
cloud computing unit we cannot wait to
start our new life in Finland we are
also excited I hope you found this video
valuable and entertaining please ask any
questions about the topics covered in
this video in the comment box below our
experts will assist you in addressing
your problems so thank you for watching
stay safe and keep learning with simply
learn staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here